دون توافق على مشروع قرار فلسطيني رافض
لاتفاق التطبيع الاماراتي الاسرائيلي
اختتم اجتماع عادي للجامعه العربيه عقد
على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه عبر الفيديو
كونفرنس ثمت امور لافته ففي كلمته في
الجلسه الافتتاحيه لم يشهر احمد ابو الغيط
الامين العام للجامعه العربيه مباشره الى
الاتفاق الاماراتي الاسرائيلي واكتفى
بالاشاره الى ان حق كل الوله سيادي الى في
مباشره سياستها الخارجيه بالصوره التي
تراها هو حق لا جدال فيه هو موقف يتناقض
مع كلمات مطوله لابو الغيط ادان فيها
خيارات استخدمت فيها حكومه الوفاق الليبيه
حقها السيادي باعتبارها حكومه معترفا بها
دوليا السؤال العريض ما هو حجم وطبيعه
الدور المتبقي للجامعه العربيه تقرير ناصر
اي
الطاهر مشهد صادم لكنه واقع انه نتاج اول
اتفاق تطبيع من نوعه بين دوله عربيه وا را
منذ نحو ربع قرن ليس حدثا عابرا كي يسقط
من حسابات جامعه العرب بل المظله الرسميه
لانظمتها وعملها
المشترك فلسطين التي تراس الدوره الحاليه
لمجلس الجامعه على المستوى الوزاري حاولت
منذ البدء ان تحدث
فرقع سعت قبلا لعقد اجتماع طارئ للجامعه
العربيه لبحث الاتفاق التطبيعي لكن دوله
عربيه لم يسمي وزير الخارجيه الفلسطيني
وقالت صحف انها البحرين اعترضت وطلبت
الاستعاضه عنه بالدوره
العاديه ثم حاول الفلسطينيون استصدار قرار
او اضافه بند يدين خطوه التطبيع
الاماراتيه حتى لا يفهم الاجتماع مباركه
او غطاء لها لكن المسعى اصطدم برفض الدوله
نفسها فيما هددت دوله اخرى كما قال الرياض
المالكي بتقديم مشروع قرار بديل يضفي
الشرعيه على اتفاق التطبيع المسمى
ابراهام بل ان مصادر فلسطينيه تحدثت عن
مماطله الامين العام للجامعه احمد ابو
الغيط نفسه في تعميم مشروع القرار
الفلسطيني في حين عجل الرجل كما يبدو
بتعميم طلب بعدم بحثه تقدمت به مملكه
البحرين ودعمته دوله
الامارات كانت تلك عقبه اخرى امام صدور
ادانه صريحه للخروج عن مبادئ مبادره
السلام
العربيه موقف السعوديه جاء متسقا مع روح
تلك المبادره التي طرحتها في بيروت عام
2002 فقد ايدت المملكه جميع الجهود
الراميه للتوصل الى حل عادل وشامل للقضيه
الفلسطينيه على اساس حدود عام
67 سلطنه عمان من جانبها ذكرت بانه لا
يمكن تحقيق سلام شامل وعادل بين الدول
العربيه واسرائيل دون حل الدولتين المبني
على مبدا الارض مقابل السلام انها من جمله
التصريحات التي بدت وفيه للاجماع العربي
على القضيه
الفلسطينيه اجماع ترى السلطه الفلسطينيه
بان اعلان اغسطس الثلاثي بين اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده والامارات ينبغي الا
ينتقص منه ليست المساله بهذا اليسر الم
يجعل البعض مثلا من سياده الدول مبررا
لابعاد التطبيع عن دائره الادانه العربيه
الرسميه انها مقاربه المسؤول الاول في
امانه الجامعه يطلقها من دوله المقر التي
ايدت خطوه ابو
ظبي تعقيبا على اتفاق التطبيع الاماراتي
الاسرائيلي يقول احمد ابو الغيط ان لدى كل
دوله عربيه الحق في ان تتخذ القرار
السيادي الذي
يناسبها يقصد ان تحديد الدول الاعضاء
علاقه
مع غيرها من الدول هو من صميم اعمال
السياده الوطنيه فهل ينسحب ذلك على
الملفات العربيه كافه في ليبيا مثلا نجد
ابو الغيط الذي رافع لمصلحه ما سمي اعلان
القاهره ينافح عن السياده الليبيه بوجه
التدخلات العسكريه الخارجيه لكنه يخص
بالذكر تركيا مع ان من استدعاها بكل سياده
هي حكومه الوفاق المعترف بها دوليا تلك
التي تمثل ليبيا حصرا لدى الجامعه
العربيه ولمناقشة
الاسرائيلي الا ان الامر تم رفضه ما
تفسيرك يعني بالتاكيد هذا شيء مؤسف لان
يعني القضيه الفلسطينيه كانت هي
الحلقه ربما الوحيده التي تربط الانظمه
العربيه المختلفه والمتناثر في سياساتها
حول قضيه واحده اليوم للاسف الشديد تنكسر
هذه الح الحلقه
الجامعه بين الدول العربيه وبعضها البعض
و يعني هذا ليس غريبا على الجامعه لانها
عباره عن مجمع ايرادات الانظمه ولا
ا علاقه لها بالشعوب على اي نحو حيث ان
البلدان العربيه جميعا يعني ت تفتقر
الى الديمقراطيه والتمثيل النيابي الصحيح
الذي الذي يجعل المؤسسات الرسميه معبره
تمام التعبير عن الشعب ولكن
يعني هذا الامر الذي حدث اليوم يكسر سنوات
من الادانات الشكليه المتمثله في الشجب
والادانه دون اتخاذ قرارات فعليه كانت
عواصم عربيه كثيره لها علاقات من تحت
الطاوله مع اسرائيل حتى
اشد منتقدي اسرائيل علنا لهم علاقات للاسف
الشديد وعلاقات شراكه امنيه وتجاريه و
ولكن حتى لو كانت ادانات شكليه سيد مجدي
شندي كان اسمها بالنهايه ادانات انتقال
الامر الان للتصدي لجهود الوفد الفلسطيني
لحصول على ادانه لهذا
القرار او لهذا الاتفاق بين الامارات
واسرائيل ما خطورته
وطبعا يعني حسنا ان الجامعه لم تنقلب على
ذاتها
واكدت يعني ان مساله تطبيع هي مساله
سياديه لكن هذا لا ينال من الاجماع العربي
شيئا حول ضروره اقامه دوله فلسطينيه على
حدود
1967 وكانت هناك خطابات بعض وزراء
الخارجيه خطابات مست سخه من ازمنه سابقه
يعني تعتبر ضم الضفه الغربيه جريمه
حرب كل ما حاولت تفاديه الجامعه العربيه
اليوم هو عدم ادانه سعود الى هذه المواقف
الرسميه التي ظهرت في هذا الاجتماع ولكن
اسمح لي ان انتقل الى الدكتور لقاء مكي
دكتور بالنسبه للوفد الفلسطيني تم طلب رفض
الاجتماع الطارئ تم طلب اضافه بند ادانه
الى هذا الاجتماع العادي
دوله اخرى حسب مصادر فلسطينيه او حسب رياض
المالكي هددت بتقديم مشروع قرار بديل يطفي
الشرعيه على اتفاق ابرهم مصادر فلسطينيه
تحدثت عن مماطله الامين العام للجامعه
نفسه في تعميم مشروع القرار الفلسطيني في
حين عجل الرجل كما يبدو بتعميم طلب بعدم
بحثه بعدم بحث طلب الوفد الفلسطيني تقدمت
به مملكه البحرين ودعمته دوله الامارات
هذا الكلام مقتبس من تقرير زميلنا ناصر
ايه ال طاهر يعني قراته فقط لاسالك ما
الذي تعرض له الوفد الفلسطيني هناك في
الجامعه العربيه ما هذا ما الذي تعرضت له
فلسطين في الحقيقه ليست فقط الوفد
الفلسطيني هو جزء مما تتعرض له فلسطين
والقضيه الفلسطينيه يعني
هذا لا استطيع فقط ان اسميها مؤامره يعني
هذا الحصار الذي يتعرض له السلطه
الفلسطينيه والوفد الفلسطيني هو بالتاكيد
جزء بسيط من مظاهر الحصار او التامر على
القضيه الفلسطينيه كل القضيه الفلسطينيه
اصبحت الان في مهب الريح اصبحت يعني ليست
من الاولويات على الاقل في السياسه
العربيه الجامعه العربيه قامت بالاساس في
عام
45 لتوحيد الدول العربيه وكان البند الاول
دائما فيها هو القضيه الفلسطينيه حتى
مؤسسه فلسطيني يعني اول عمين عام هو
فلسطيني بالتالي كان هناك يعني قضيه
مركزيه تجمع الجميع الان هي القضيه
المركزيه لم تعد كذلك
الوضع العربي عموما في اسوا حالاته على
الصعيد الامني والصعيد الاستراتيجي ولا
ننسى ان اداره الجامعه العربيه هي مرهونه
بالقرار في داخل مصر يعني هي دائما كان
يقال انها جزء من وزاره الخارجيه المصريه
ومحكوم بايرادات بعض الدول ولذلك حتى سلوك
الامين العام السيد احمد ابو الغيط كان
دوما مرهون بمواقف دول معينه في
الجامعه لا يتخطاها في حين هو يهاجم دول
عربيه اخرى على خلاف مع هذه الدول التي
يمثلها او يتعاطف معها او او يعني ينحاز
لها بالتالي لا يمكن القول ان اداره
الجامعه العربيه الامانه العامه هي في وضع
محايد وفي وضع قانوني اقصد يعني انها تنفذ
ايرادات او قوانين او ميثاق الجامعه على
الاقل ما جدو توجه الوفد الفلسطيني او
تامله اذا من هذا الاجتماع او من يعني
اجتماعات كهذه كان يجب ان يفعل ذلك لسببين
الاول هو توثيقي يعني يجب ان يوضع هذا في
برامج الجامعه كي يوثق انه قام الجامع
الوفد الفلسطيني بكذا والامر الثاني انه
كان يريد ان يحرج الزعماء العرب وان يصل
الى علىق موقف يعني ربما يستطيع الوصول
الى موقف يثبت حاله التنازلات القائمه
يثبتها يعني لا تنفرط السبحه تماما يعني
لا يكن هناك بعد الامارات دول اخرى لكن ما
حصل في الحقيقه هو بالضبط ما اراد الوفد
الفلسطيني ان يتفاداه الان اذا نذكر تطبيع
مصر واسرائيل في عام 78 كام ديفيد قمه
بغداد اللي صارت فورا قاطعت مصر وعشر
سنوات او 11 سنه مصر مقاطعه لم يجر احد من
الدول العربيه على ان يقول انا تطبيع
تطبيع مع انه كان بعض الدول تتعامل مع
اسرائيل لكن لم يجر احد حتى عام 89 حينما
عادت وعادت الجامع عام 90 الى القاهره حين
ذاك في 93 صار اوسلو 94 وادي عربه وانفرطت
السبحه لذلك هذا الموقف اللي اللي هو بدون
موقف في الحقيقه اللام موقف ااء ما حصل
بين الامارات هو فقط اعاده تاكيد ما حصل ه
هو لا موقف يعني بمؤشر صفري ام لا موقف
بمؤشر سلبي هذه المره هو بالحقيقه اذا
اردنا ان هو اعطاه صفري باعتبار ان احنا
ما لنا علاقه قضيه سياديه لكن هو بالتاكيد
يقول للجميع راحتكم للجميع في الجامعه
العربيه كما تشاؤون انتم لكن سيد مجدي
شندي كان يريد ان يشير الى مواقف الرسميه
التي خرجت بالفعل يعني وزراء الخارجيه
العرب في خطاباتهم اكدوا تمسكهم بالقضيه
الفلسطينيه وبان حلها يجب ان يكون مبني
على قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه والسلام
العادل وبادره السلام حت الامارات قالت
نفس الشيء قالت نحن ندافع عن الحق
الفلسطيني ولكن هذا كلام يعني يعني كلام
شنو وزنه امام الوقائع على الارض احنا
نتكلم عن وقائع على الارض ولذلك حتى
المبادره العربيه السعوديه تمسكت بها بهذا
الاجتماع واللي هي طرحتها اصلا عام 2002
في بيروت هذه هذه المبادره لم اصبحت مفرغه
من المعنى ما بها محتوى لان هذا التطبيع
اج في سياق احتلال اسرائيلي لاراضي الضفه
وانهاء حل الدولتين الحل الواقعي يعني
اقصد القدره الواقعيه لحل الدولتين اللي
تنادي بال المبادره العربيه بالتالي احنا
نتكلم عن مبادره لم يعد لها قيمه واقعيه
على الارض والتطبيع بين الامارات واسرائيل
اج في سياق دعوه اسرائيل لدوله يهوديه
يعني احنا نتكلم عن واقع وعن انشاء سيد
مجدي شندي حسن الشيخ عضو حركه فتح ووزير
هيئه الشؤون المدنيه الفلسطيني قال ان
الجامعه اشبعت الجميع في المنطقه ادانات
الا اسرائيل من خلال كلامك
اسالك ما هي مقاربه الجامعه العربيه
اليوم في هذا الوقت للقضيه
الفلسطينيه ما هي
رؤيتها يعني الجامعه
العربيه على موقفها ايضا من التمسك بدوله
فلسطينيه لكنها لا تريد ان تحرج دوله
اصبحت ذات ثقل في صناعه القرار العربي
والحقيقه نحن لو
نظرنا الامارات بالتاكيد يعني هذا هذا امر
مفهوم لكن اذا تحدثنا
عن الضعف الحقيقي الجامعه والوفاه
الحقيقيه للجامعه نجد ان الجامعه العربيه
ربما توفيت في 28 سبتمبر
1970 حينما توفي جمال عبد الناصر الذي كان
يمثل اداه ل وداعيه
للوحده العربيه وانسجام المواقف وكان اخر
ما فعله في حياته هو ابرام اتفاق بين
الاردن الفلسطينيين وانهاء ايلول الاسود
منذ ذلك التاريخ بدا الموقف العربي في
التراجع لا ننسى ان السلطه الفلسطينيه
نفسها وانا لا اريد ان الوم السلطه في
الوقت الحالي لكنها كانت
داعيه للدول العربيه الى تطبيع مع اسرائيل
وتتصور ان ذلك يمكن ان يسهل من مهمتها وان
يسرع
ب اتجاه يعني ابرا
افاق تطبيع تطبيع مع اسرائيل يعني كورقه
ضغط للحصول على مكاسب
للفلسطينيين وليس بالشكل الذي تم بين
الامارات واسرائيل يعني تطبيع حتى بدون
مقابل بالتاكيد يعني هو هو المؤسف في
الموضوع يعني ان كل الدول العربيه كانت
تعلق قرار التطبيع
حتى تحصل على مكاسب للفلسطينيين الان
تنكسر هذه
الحلقه وتتجه دول عربيه الى التطبيع
المباشر مع اسرائيل دون اي شروط
وكانه نوع من الانسحاق التام وهذا بمفهوم
الجامع العربيه في الفتره الناصريه كان
كان يعتبر تواطؤا وخيانه لم تعد هذه
المفاهيم موجوده واصبحت كل دوله تتحدث عن
مصالحها الذات طيب النظر عن الشان العربي
في اطار المصلحه الذاتيه الامين العام
للجامعه احمد ابو الغيط سيد مجدي حلق تجنب
الاشاره في الجلسه الافتتاحيه لاتفاق
التطبيع الاماراتي الاسرائيل لكنه اشار
الى حق كل دوله السياد في مباشره سيادتها
بالطريقه
المناسبه لها في اشاره الى ما فعلته
الامارات لماذا لم يكن الامر كذلك عندما
وقعت حكومه الوفاق الوطني في ليبيا اتفاقا
مع
تركيا يعني شوفي لا ينبغي ان نساوي بين
القضيه الفلسطينيه وهي قضيه مركزيه دفع
العرب يعني من اعمارهم ومن اقواتهم دفعوا
شهداء ودفعوا جرحى ودفعوا موارد اقتصاديه
لا نريد ان نساويها
بمساله اختلاف خصمين في
ا في ليبيا وبالتالي يعني هذه المساله لا
تجوز المقر نتحدث هنا نحن نتحدث عن
الحكومه حكومه الوفاق الوطني هي الممثل
الشرعي لليبيا في الجامعه العربيه سيد
مجدي
شندي يعني ما هو مش مطلوب ان احنا ندافع
عن تركيا دلوقتي تركيا هي الاساس الذي
اضعف العالم العربي ليس مطلوبا الان عن
ندافع عن تركيا مطلوب ان ندافع عن الحق
الفلسطيني الا امين العام هوير الفكره ان
ان تعامل اسرائيل على الاقل على الاقل
بهذا الحشد الذي تم الاعداد له في في
اجتماعات الجامعه العربيه ان تعامل كما
عملت تركيا ربما كان ذلك كافيا بالنسبه
للوفد
الفلسطيني تركيا تعادي المصالح العربيه
مثلها مثل اسرائيل وان لا ننسى ان انقره
من اوائل العواصم التي اعترفت باسرائيل
وظل الطيران الاسرائيلي يتدرب في مجالها
الجوي لا نريد اليوم ان نغسل
ساحات تركيا ونقدمها باعتبارها يعني
المدافعه عن الحق الفلسطيني ولماذا لم
تتبنى الجامعه العربيه اتفاقها مع حكومه
منقوصه الشرعيه في طرابلس الان نحن بصدد
مناقشه القضيه الفلسطينيه ما حدث اليوم هو
كسر لحلقه مهمه جدا كانت تجمع العالم
العربي على ولكن حتى لو حت لك ما شئ سيد
مجدي ولكن المفارقه حاضره بقوه والمقارنه
حاضره بقوه انقل سؤالي لك سي دكتور لقاء
مكي هذا الموضوع التحدث الان السياده
مساله السياده كحجه لابرام اتفاقيات خاصه
مع اسرائيل او مع اي دوله اخرى كما ذكر
ابو الغيط في مقابل ما
شهدناه ضد ما قيل وقتها انه تدخل تركي او
اتفاق منفرد لحكومه الوفاق مع تركيا يعني
انا اعتقد انه حضرتك تتحدثين عن يعني
كمثال لعمليه انتقائيه يعني او السلوك
الانتقائي لامانه العامه للجامعه العربيه
في القضايا التي تواجه العالم العربي او
تواجه الجامعه سواء كانت ليبيا او سواها
القضيه لا تتعلق فقط يعني بتركيا او غير
تركيا هناك موقف من الدول التي يمالئ
الامين العام تجاه تركيا وايران ولذلك هي
ليست صدفه ان توجه الجامعه العربيه
اسلحتها تجاه تركيا بغض النظر عن موقف
تركيا من من العالم العربي سيئه متدخله او
غير متدخله لكن القضيه ليست متعلقه بتركيا
بل متعلقه بموقف المتحزبين مع ابو الغيط
او المتحزبين لهم هذه الدول التي حملته
على هذا الموقف هذه الاشكاليه ان الجامعه
العربيه لم تعد تهتم بالموقف الاستراتيجي
العربي او بمصالح الدول العربيه او
بالقضايا المركزيه ولكن بمصالح بعض الدول
في المسيطره في هذه الجامعه لا اكثر ولا
اقل هذه الاشكاليه التي اضعفت الجامعه
واصبحت هذه المؤسسه رهينه لايرادات بعض
الدول في في العالم العربي الدكتور لقاء
مكي الباحثه الاول بمركز الجزيره لدراسه
ضيفنا في الاستوديو مجدي شندي رئيس تحرير
صحيفه المشهد الاسبوعيه ضيفنا من القاهره
عبر الانترنت شكرا جزيلا لكما بهذا نصر
مشاهدينا الى نهايه حصد الليله الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ان